this is
a situation that's affected many people
and this is my reality that i've grown
up in it's the only reality i know and
i'm allowed to speak about that as jamie
lynn spears his feud with her big sis
brittany rages on it's an explosion a
source tells et that the 40-year-old pop
star's recent trip to hawaii with fiance
sam eskari was just what she needed from
here on it's it's amazing it's heaven
from here on out well not all heaven the
spear sisters have been at odds
following the release of jamie lynn's
memoir things i should have said it's a
healing process that i know that i'm
working through i think we have to
respect each other's process as we go
through it while promoting her book the
former nickelodeon star sat down for an
in-depth chat with call her daddy host
alex cooper about growing up in
brittany's shadow it doesn't matter who
your sister is or if something has
caused you pain or this is your
experience nothing should diminish your
experience
it's like my whole life i kind of felt
like i didn't matter
so it's like i just wish
that mattered brittany reacted to the
interview in a series of explosive
expletive-filled social media posts
calling jamie lynn a selfish little brat
amongst other insults and now a source
tells e.t brit needed some time away to
decompress from all the book drama quote
britney felt overwhelmed and needed an
escape now my main thing is to enjoy
life
and take today take one day at a time
and i try to live by that our source
adds that brittany and sam quote really
love their alone time and feel most at
peace in hawaii it's their sacred place
as a couple
after part one of jamie lynn's call her
daddy interview dropped the lucky singer
sent her sister a cease and desist
letter calling on jamie lynn to stop
quote referencing britney derogatorily
in interviews threatening further legal
action if she refused jamie lynn
responded with a letter of her own
calling out brittany for her quote vile
posts on social media claiming that her
book isn't about her big sister a
sentiment the mom of two also shared
with e.t this book isn't about me trying
to clear up anything it's about me using
my voice and showing my daughters that
your voice is important that's what this
book is about in part two of jamie
lynn's call her daddy tell-all the now
30-year-old shared a text that she
allegedly sent both britney and sam in
2020. in an effort to prove that she
tried to help her sister get out of her
conservatorship november 11th 2020 10 45
pm and then i resent it to her boyfriend
the next morning but according to e.t
source
sam isn't happy about all that
quote he feels very protective over
britney and also himself et source says
sam has been britney's rock adding that
he's used to being her support system
behind the scenes i'm really blessed
quote brittany and sam are both trying
to focus on the good in their lives and
stay positive but jamie lynn's interview
really upset both of them i don't have
all the answers i'm just trying to do
the best i can every day with everything
that is you know going on just like many
other families in this world and despite
all the drama a source previously told
et quote jamie lynn has genuinely always
wanted the best for brittany and she
loves britney with all of her heart
despite their complicated relationship
[Music]